next las vegas officials give an update
on the investigation into sunday night's
shooting this is 35 minutes
all right good afternoon everyone i'm
obviously sheriff lombardo clark county
um this will be our fourth media
briefing since the incident took place
uh yesterday evening
i'm going to give you just a short
synopsis of our updates and then we have
a other individuals here standing behind
me that are going to make some comments
reference other issues associated with
today's events
so
there's two things we're attempting to
achieve one is we have to finish
processing the scenes
we have three separate scenes we are
working out actually it will be four at
this point
so we have the 32nd floor of the room at
the mandalay bay we have the event
location
the house in mesquite and then now we
have swat standing by getting ready to
hit the house in
northern nevada
at this point we did in the last
briefing i was unable to tell you what
we retrieved from the house in mesquite
we retrieved in the excess
aaron how many firearms was it
an excess of 18 additional firearms
some explosives and several thousand
rounds of ammo
along with some electronic devices that
we are evaluating at this point
um
i mentioned that swat is about to breach
the house up in northern nevada and then
i'm going to give you an update on the
casualty numbers we are currently
standing at 527
for individuals injured
and individuals that have died or passed
away 59.
um so what we're doing at this point we
have several people calling about
personal items located at the stadium
we are not done processing that scene
yet and once we are done processing the
scene we will make arrangements for
people that attended the stadium that
believe they have personal items there
to respond to the area and we will help
you retrieve your items
at this point i want to bring greg
castle forward from the county fire
department
and he will give you an update on the
family resource center prior to that i
think it's important for and i
appreciate for you to put this out for
the people families that are responding
to the las vegas area
some local proprietaries have
offered up
rooms for the family members at no
charge and that is the boyd group
stations casinos
the south point with mr gone and also
siegel suites so one more time the boy
group stations casinos the south point
with mr gone and the seagull suites so
individuals responding to the las vegas
area in need of accommodations
those
individual properties will accommodate
you so greg
thank you sheriff
my name is greg castle fire chief of the
clark county fire department and as the
sheriff said there's a couple things i
want to mention the first off is the
family assistance center the family
assistance center is set up right now
it's a combination of police department
fire department the coroner's office and
other local entities working together to
provide the services for the families
and for the coming that are coming into
town or that are still here trying to
handle what has happened with their
loved ones they're providing all kinds
of services as the sheriff said many
places have stepped up to provide
flights
housing food transportation and many
other things that's that's a wonderful
thing for our community have come
forward and have done this facility is
located in the south hall the convention
center uh s2 and it's pretty much taking
up the entire south hall there's also a
donation drop-off area that's been
set up to facilitate people wanting to
drop off non-perishable goods over there
at that site water and so forth
those that entrance to that is off of
sierra vista
right just west of this
convention center area command metro
building that's at joe w brown in sierra
vista
so i'd like to take an opportunity right
now to thank the men and women of the
fire department's clark county fire
department obviously very near and dear
to my heart las vegas fire and rescue
henderson fire department and north las
vegas fire department as we were all
teamed up there last night doing what
we've trained for so many years we wish
would never happen but we definitely had
a plan in place and we were able to
execute that plan as well as we possibly
could we had 108 firefighters on scene
we have a 155 unit hours just for the
clark county fire department alone spent
last night handling that scene teaming
up with our partners from the law
enforcement to reach as many people as
fast as we could and to try to do as
much as we could as we could for the
community i also want to take a moment
to recognize community ambulance they
were there as a standby medical at that
scene last night they had five or six
ambulances there they immediately threw
critically wounded patients into their
ambulances and transported from that
scene and also american medical response
amr and medic west ambulance they
brought all hands on deck they brought
in all of their employees they rallied
everything they could from pickup trucks
to vans to all their available
ambulances to bring extra medical
supplies down to a staging area for us
and to make those resources available to
our community during that time of need
so i want to give a big shout out to
those private ambulance companies that
have done a wonderful thing for us last
night as a responders
and from the fire department side i'll
take a few questions
i could not quantify that but i have
worked here for 30 years and i have
never seen that many ambulances that i
saw last night
hundreds dozens dozens and dozens
that's 108 firefighters combined from
those resources i mentioned those four
fire departments
what types of injuries were there
transported to the hospital
there's a wide range of injuries you
know from gunshots to shrapnel wounds to
trample injuries to people jumping
fences trying to egress and getting hurt
one way or another
so it was a wide range of those types of
incidents
injuries cheaply explain the
comment or tell us what the staging
process is
there are some who said it took a long
time for people to finally get into the
venue
well we had multiple uh branches and
divisions set up last night to cover
that large area and i can't speak to how
long it took him to get into that venue
but we had some we had some issues right
out of the chute or right out of the
start because
things were going on we didn't know
where the gunfire was we weren't sure it
was safe to commit our people at that
time and that's some of our policies and
procedures are to try and make our
people as safe as possible we know
they're going to go into a dangerous
situation that's why we do it in a
format with called a rescue task force
with the police departments four of our
personnel three to four police officers
going into harm's way which is something
that even 10 years ago in this valley
would have never taken place because we
had never trained on it we had never
planned on it
we had no on-duty injuries of any of our
emergency response personnel last night
did you have any opportunities
uh from my fire department no
greg can we give john
sure
john
thank you greg thank you sheriff
again my name is john fudenberg i'm the
coroner of clark county and i'd like to
first of all just ask that everybody
keeps
those involved in this incident and
their thoughts and prayers and and as as
as well as the the first responders all
government agencies all of us that have
come together and working on this
incident please keep us in your thoughts
and prayers and
know that we're working very hard to
make sure that we take care of the
families who have loved ones involved in
this incident
i'd like to take a moment and talk a
little bit more about the family
assistance center as chief castle
mentioned we have that set up at the cas
at the convention center
we're we're fully operational right
there right now excuse me
and
we've met with multiple families we're
continuing to interview the families and
the goal of that center
is to provide families information about
the identification of their loved ones
and as importantly to collect
information from them so we can make the
identifications as fast as possible so
we're working uh
very hard at making those
identifications out of respect for the
family i'd rather not go into any
details about the decedents or their
injuries at this point
i'm available to answer any questions
that anybody may have yes sir
has there been an issue with that well i
would like to say we're about as quick
as equipped as anybody in the country i
don't know that anybody can be fully
equipped to handle this but we've gotten
support through grant money and our
county commission through the years
we've trained and we've exercised and
we're putting that training and
exercising in place right now and i
think our staff along with the police
departments and fire departments are
doing a heck of a good job in handling
this all things considered
yes sir can go ahead you have to ask do
you have enough
space at the corners office for 59. we
do have enough space right now yes sir
go ahead
as of right now all of the confirmed
fatalities have been have been recovered
and they have been transported to our
office yes
does that include the shooter or not
i believe that that includes the shooter
but again that's that number could be
fluid
so i you know that number unfortunately
may go up uh and and i don't want to
give an exact number and confirmation at
this point
you know i think we're handling it about
as good as could be expected i think
we're all everybody in this room
everybody in our county right now is
suffering as a result of this tragic
incident so i appreciate you asking but
i think we're handling it very well and
our staff's doing a darn good job at
managing it thank you mr corner are you
able to assess the
type of injuries that led to these
deaths
were they followed by gunshots
you know again as chief castle uh
mentioned he spoke a little bit about
the injuries i'd rather not speak to the
injuries the families want answers and
i'd like to i'd prefer out of respect
for them to give them the answers before
we we make those public
so i'm not going to answer that at this
time ken thank you
any other questions
okay thank you very much for your time
sheriff
thank you once again
for being here and spreading this
information to our community i want to
reiterate what i said earlier and i want
to have a special shout out to
the sheriff and uh
chief castle and the men and women are
first responders that are there and as i
said previously when you see one of
these men and women in their uniforms
please tell them thank you
they went in when everybody was running
out but for the fact
that their selfless actions we would
have hundreds more casualties than we
are currently facing there's no doubt in
my mind i was on the crime scene
it's horrific
and these folks did an absolutely
incredible job went above and beyond
uh i want to assure everyone that you
know it's in your control right now las
vegas is a safe place to be
it's a safe place to visit we encourage
people to continue to come here we have
been deluged with donations people
bringing sandwiches bringing water bring
blankets bringing those sort of things
it's almost to the point we can't handle
any more donations at the convention
center the sheriff and i spoke to you
earlier regarding the blood donations
after we brought that out early this
morning when the sheriff and i talked
and we put out a call for blood and we
have a six to eight hour wait in all of
our blood centers right now donations
are being given appointments are being
made for thursday and friday that's how
far in advance we are we set up a
gofundme account because the sheriff and
i thought that we could maybe help some
of these victims with
funeral expenses with travel expenses
as it relates to the families you have
to be coming in from out of town we
still have over 500 emergency rooms we
started that gofundme account it now has
almost 15 000 contributions in excess of
1.2 million dollars
has been donated by uh generous people
around the country that you know care
about what we're doing the hate that
this one individual this lone wolf
rained down on our community and on the
mgm village park was met with an
outpouring of love by our entire
community and we will get through this
together and we'll get through this as
one community so thank you very much for
being here and our thoughts and prayers
are with all of the families
well thank you very much i'm dina titus
i represent uh nevada's first district
which includes the fabulous las vegas
strip and the scene of this horrendous
act so many times i have welcomed people
to las vegas conventions or special
events never imagined that i would be
standing here trying to offer
solace and service to those who would be
harmed or killed by such and such an act
my office is serving as a clearing house
we don't want to get in the way of this
wonderful law enforcement and first
responders who have done such a good job
but we want to be there in any way we
can we've gotten many many phone calls
into the office from people around the
country looking to find out where their
folks are where they heard or in the
hospital were they killed we're trying
to pass that information on to the
appropriate place a couple of
immigration calls that we're trying to
to help with as well i would point out
in addition to the services that have
already been mentioned
thomas and mack opened up as a temporary
refuge for people who were put out of
their hotel rooms the clark county
school district has offered its
counselors to the public if they are
needed we were contacted by airbnb they
are also offering
facilities to anybody who needs to come
into town to
to see about family members the
community is stepping up we heard acts
of heroism off-duty police officers
helping people shelter pointing out
where they thought the shots were coming
from
a friend of one of my staff members was
being trampled they were running out
somebody grabbed and pulled them into a
van just to be safe a total stranger we
were standing on the corner outside of
umc and a car slowed down and said where
can we go to give blood that's the kind
of community that we have here las vegas
is resilient and with everybody pulling
together we will get through this so
thank you very much to law enforcement
first responders our fire department
those medical personnel who are taking
care of people in the parking lots of
hospitals everybody stepped up and we
can't say thank you enough
thank you i'm jackie rosen and i
represent nevada's third district just
right outside the las vegas strip and i
reiterate what everyone said here our
first responders our hospital staff our
hotel staff firefighters ambulance
police and i stand before you not just
as a congresswoman but as a mother a
daughter a sister
a friend and a member of this community
and like congresswoman titus said we are
a strong community we know how to
fight we know how to be resilient and we
know how to pull together and that's
just exactly what we're going to do so
today we're going to come together with
all of our community partners our hotels
airbnb our lyft and uber our taxi
drivers we're going to do everything we
can to support the victims their
families and we're going to move forward
and we're going to do it together in
strength so i appreciate everybody's
support that's helped us again
thank
you
sure thank you and uh not a lot to add
to what's already been said here um
united states senator dean heller but
what i do want to add is that we'll
never forget october 1st 2017.
think about that october 1st 2017 will
be a day to remember here in las vegas
and it's a day that we'll remember for
years to come as we remember and think
about how dangerous this world can be
i'm very grateful to the sheriff's
department all the first responders and
everything that they've done the help
and the support from people around the
country the number of phone calls that
we've received the condolences
that are flowing into this into this
community are second to none and i want
to thank our whole congressional
delegation for working together linking
arms and trying to move this community
forward forward nevada is strong nevada
will remain strong we'll get through
this we'll all do it working together
thank you
carolyn goodman mayor the great city of
las vegas
and the outpouring of attention love
sympathy and offers of help not only
have come from around this country from
mayors and governors but also from
abroad and we want to thank for sure all
of the law enforcement and first first
responders that have come in from other
parts of the state as well as from los
angeles to help us out here the number
of people that have come and gotten in
line to give blood has really become an
issue that we're going to learn from we
haven't been able to keep up with it
people are frustrated they love this
community they love what it represents
and they want to do something about it
it's been simply incredible and to learn
that this wonderful fund that the
sheriff had set up is over a million
dollars you can just feel the heartbeat
of the people that call las vegas and
nevada home
most especially in talking and i spent
last night in the hospital at umc and
over at valley to talk to some of those
who were less seriously injured how
confused they were about the issue there
because as you know when you go to one
of these outdoor entertainment and even
the inner inner side the arena ones
you're usually given a bracelet
identification
and uh because they were up front and
because they were in a confined
environment the places to get out were
less less open to them but the sounds
and talking to the patients hearing
different sounds because they're
thinking it's fireworks or it's part of
the technology of the music that's being
played they could tell me that they were
thinking was coming from different areas
and the fact that our first responders
in law enforcement acted so quickly so
professionally and attended to the need
right then and there and were able to
get up into the mandalay bay in four
minutes is simply an incredible feat it
is something that saved thousands of
lives we had over 22 000 people there in
a small area and it's simply amazing how
efficiently law enforcement and first
responders worked you heard those words
from our president he called me on my
cell phone and spoke with the sheriff
and our attorney general with whom i was
speaking and just whatever he could
provide and he is coming out here the
question is
what can be done people are asking
emails are coming phone calls are coming
in and i'm sure everyone that's standing
here has received them this is a
remarkable community of people who are
involved who do care and this heinous
crime
this maniac
could do such destruction to so many
people we even lost one of our
members at our city hall and so it's
it's a very difficult time while the sun
is shining in las vegas it is a very
dark and black day and as i'm sure that
was said october 1st 2017
will be one of the darkest days ever and
hopefully never again
thank you thank you sheriff and thank
you law enforcement and first responders
simply unbelievable tonight at
five o'clock at city hall will be the
first of i'm sure several vigils five
o'clock city hall pastor troy will be
leading that and i'm sure there'll be
many others this is a loving and caring
community and i'm proud to be its mayor
thank you i'm mark hutchinson lieutenant
governor of the great state of nevada
the governor was here earlier and said
that
this has been our finest hour as a state
uh it's been our finest hour as a city
it's been our finest hour i think among
our finest hours is americans
if you were taken into umc medical
center the trauma center there and you
were alive you're still alive today
you're still alive at this hour
the amount of skill and professionalism
that was shown by those doctors and
those nurses and those medical
professionals is extraordinary something
that we can be very very proud of
same is true if you went to uh
spring valley hospital if you were alive
you're still alive
could not be prouder of those
men and women who saved so many lives in
las vegas today
and it was saved so many lives in las
vegas last night
as i went into these uh hospital rooms
throughout the day
as many of my my friends and colleagues
behind me and they are my friends and
colleagues
and there are true nevadans and true
americans
uh they heard the same stories that i
did these heroic efforts of ordinary
people from all over this country
i'll tell you how how personal it is i
just came from
spring valley hospital and there karen
uh was injured seriously
and was carried away from the scene and
she said uh if i ever had a chance to
thank this individual would i please
thank him his name's sean topper
who carried her from the scene and she
said if you get a chance to ever get a
hold of him or reach him let him know
that i i made it
and she was uh she said that he was her
guardian angel that day
and we saw and heard
story after story like this
ordinary americans helping other
ordinary americans it's a great day for
america it's a very sad day for
um for las vegas my hometown
uh tragedy beyond words
but this was the day when americans
helped americans make it through the
night and i say god bless them all thank
you mr hutchinson
can you clarify did you tell us that
everyone who went to those hospitals
none of them died at the hospital when i
was at umc uh today i was told by the
trauma surgeons that if they everyone
who made it into uh
umc alive was still alive there were
those who were not alive when they
arrived
um that was the latest information that
i got as well there may be more updated
information but that was the information
that i got and uh wanted to make the
point that there was extraordinary skill
uh shown by the medical professionals at
umc did anybody go to any hospitals out
of this state
i don't know the answer to that yeah we
had one individual rest of my
recollection in california thank you
well i want to thank everybody for
coming so just one more clarification
besides the vigil at city hall there's
an additional vigil at 5 p.m at the
guardian angel cathedral
and that is adjacent to the encore hotel
guardian angel cathedral at 5 pm
so i'm happy to answer some questions at
this time
or anything like that
we haven't located anything of that
description yet
tell us how many guns were
found in the room
uh 16 in the room
um we have calibers ranging from 308 to
223. is there any evidence that you can
video
phone or laptop
i'm not aware of that at this point
one at a time please
surveillance
i'm not aware of that
i've been hearing that but i'm not
completely aware of it to testify to
at as it person of interest that you
determined you didn't think had anything
to do with this now that you have found
18 more guns in their home and they
apparently shared a home
um
do you revisit that and how could
someone not know what that all of that
was inside their home
i didn't say we were discontinuing the
investigation into that
female we are continuing the
investigation into that female there are
several questions that need to be
answered similar to what you propose
but she is currently out of the country
we are making arrangements to contact
her upon her return
no i believe she's in tokyo
we had a handgun also in the hotel room
um and i'm not aware of any other uh
weapons
yes ma'am did you find anything in the
suspect's car
yes we found some uh i believe it was
fertilizer is that correct todd
ammonia sulfate i can't recall the
chemical comp
ammonia nitrate
within the car we didn't have any
compounds additional to that
correct
no i believe it was tannerite i believe
it was tannerite have you have you been
investigating any kind of a gambling
debt
no i also saw that on the internet and
presented in the internet i believe some
journalism research produced that but we
haven't had the opportunity to evaluate
it
up north why are you saying
no we don't man we have to as part of
the swat team is attachment of our armor
personnel or our bomb squad and we and
we want to ensure that there's no booby
traps available
yes we did
the weapons modified
we believe so we haven't broken them
down the atf hasn't evaluated them yet
but believe i don't know if the seer
pins have been filed or whether they've
been converted to fully automatic
slow down
hard please yes we have
yes we have we haven't evaluated them
yet um the fbi has given us uh their
resources to evaluate those would the
weapons be characterized
yes would they be would any of them
modified or
purchased automatic
uh i am not aware of that we are aware
of one gun dealer that has come forward
to say that he had
sold the weapons to the suspect
but we are aware of some other
individuals that are engaged in those
transactions
not aware of las vegas we're aware of
arizona so far but we're working on
further
no there were several suitcases i can't
give you the exact number it was in
excess of 10.
from the 28th so he and methodically
just kept bringing two cases back and
forth and you know when dr wiser maybe
think you know it's a big place i get it
but
i wish that would have happened now
absolutely wish that would happen
we don't have any
have a evidence of
at this point no we don't did he stay in
one room
uh there was one large suite that had
two rooms
in the interaction with security they
believed it was between the 29th and the
32nd floor we had to evaluate each floor
moving up
did you find the room
prior to this weekend maybe
there was some talk that he might have
been like beautiful
we are researching that um we had
information that he may have attended
life is beautiful but we haven't
confirmed it yet
did you find the room
no we had complaints from uh customers
into security
yes they did
engaged by security before police
arrived no he engaged security uh he
fought he shot through the doorway and
struck security guard was unspent
yes
okay
please slow down
okay
i don't think as fast as you
no he wasn't he was shot in the
leg the shooter might have been employed
by a federal agency
um i can't confirm that or deny it um we
are still evaluating that
sure
it might be a little bit
idea but for you and some
target hardening absolutely that's a
continual conversation recently
everyone is very aware of the baller
project and that was the intent to
prevent any harm associated that so
target hardening evaluating customers
will be continual basis
we believe
my understanding of their boyfriend
girlfriend
sheriff what's the distance from the
room
to
where the shots are i would measure by
sight
just through my hunting background in
excess of 500 yards
he had scope on some some of the rifles
and did he use multiple rifles during
diesel yes he did i don't know how if he
whether he used all of them or not ken i
don't know that yet we have to break
them down and evaluate them
from the airport
a witness who said an officer shielded
them i just want you to expand on the
role of your officers during this
emergency
and
let us know how they're doing too
yeah i mean that's a very difficult
question um
well it's not difficult it's a very hard
question for me to answer because of
what they did the heroic acts uh you
know quite often we're the ones that go
in when everybody's running the other
way and then and case in point this
event that's exactly what occurred
and we asked the officers who are well
well trained to address these type of
events active shooter events
but this is different than anything
they've trained for because the active
shooter is unreachable
so but so our intent is life safety
that's our first priority in law
enforcement and i'm very proud of what
our officers did you heard earlier
i i couldn't give you i don't even want
to guess on a time can you probably do a
better job than me with the evaluation
of the video
when they can expect your traces to be
done and what are you expecting to learn
i believe that in short order i'm hoping
we'll get that
aaron you have any timeline on that
i would anticipate in the next day or
two
good for them
no we have no evidence of that when he
was engaging with your officers was
there anything
i'm not aware of anything
so
we do our standard announcements before
entry
you mentioned tannerites
no not in the vehicle in the home
yes
exactly you could buy it at any gun
store i can't i don't know what the
regulations is on the mount i don't want
to give you a bad amount but it is it's
available commercially available
no i can't recall i was told but i can't
recall
several pounds
[Music]
uh no ma'am other than what's possibly
been presented with life is beautiful
and he does live in close vicinity of
las vegas in excess of a year without
being in mesquite
players 12 cards that were found in
there have any indication that he's
familiar with that specific hotel uh no
because the player club's car did not
belong to him
i don't
i'm not aware of it some of the folks
don't seem to know who he is think he
might not have actually held his primary
residence there he's got the house of
the moon though do you know where he
actually particularly
i believe it was mesquite
i think i saw a posting and depending on
the accuracy of the internet um that the
neighbors were familiar with the
individual but he was uh reclusive
[Music]
no all the officers this will be the
last question for you um all the
officers were assigned to the event
we do have officers that were inside for
other events inside the mandalay bay as
a matter of weekly practice specifically
the nightclubs
so but i'm sure they were not aware of
what was taking place similar to the
officers at the event
officers took it upon themselves to help
the
customers exit the
grounds and some officers took it upon
themselves to immediately go to the
mandalay bay
there was a team of six officers that
approached security uh they went up uh
up the elevators after discussing the
situation with the security and give
intelligence
and they checked each floor by floor
until they located where they believed
to be the room
subsequently they approached the room
received gunfire they backed off and
swat responded
i don't recall a smoke alarm so thank
you very much i appreciate everybody's
time and your patience and we will
update you uh later this evening
todd you have a time you want to update
them
we'll shoot for 7 pm tonight for updates
of any new information
yes sir thank you thank you